I know someone's gonna enjoy that but I
don't get to enjoy it's officially 2020
and the new year is upon us
so everybody's listening to try out and
you diet a new challenge and I did
exactly that for the last 30 days with
whole 30 no added sugar no grains no
legumes no dairy no alcohol no
measurements no MSG or sulfites and no
baked junk food with approved
ingredients it's really a short list but
if you really dive in and look at the
rules each one technically eliminates
whole food groups and boy was it a
challenge for me this video sponsored by
thrive market it's an online marketplace
that makes healthy eating more
affordable they have 25 to 50% off
retail prices that's really important
healthy eating can get quite expensive
and I don't want a financial barrier
between you and a healthy lifestyle so
to take advantage of this partnership
click the link in my description sign up
with your email pips between the 1/3 or
12-month packages to me the 12-month is
a no-brainer because it's only five
bucks a month you're gonna save money
you're gonna eat healthy no matter what
diet you're following vegan paleo whole
xxx doesn't matter you can organize it
on their website however you like it's a
30-day trial so if you don't like it
cancel it get your money back
no biggie I think it's time for 30
[Music]
the original plan was to start hole 30
immediately after my birthday falls on
November 12 just turned 30 by the way
and I was a big occasion to celebrate so
I don't want to be following any
restrictive diets in that moment you
know I'm saying little sweets never hurt
nobody
cookies a milkshake oh then I began
having some serious second thoughts
no this is not an endorsement this is
not an endorsement of hole 30 for
everybody it's not a universal
recommendation in fact there are very
few Universal recommendations that
doctors give to their patients hole 30
is something I wanted to try I wanted to
see how my body responded to it if you
want a video talking about the true pros
and cons from the scientific angle of
hole 30 that's linked down below
[Music]
the rules of hole 30 a lot of them make
sense to me and I was fine following
them but there were a few that I knew
we're gonna be problematic right off the
bat and those two are no grains and no
dairy I can cut out bread that's not a
problem I've done that before when I was
gluten sensitive in the past I've
overcome that but the fact that I have
to give up brown rice quinoa things that
I eat part of a healthy diet my sushi
that's if you know what I eat that's
like my go-to meals so I was gonna be
suffering without having rice and then
to not have cheese gg's it's what makes
the world go round
it's like my favorite thing even in
salads like you need to put a little
blue cheese crumble in there to make it
taste good
so I knew right away that that was gonna
be a problem what I tried to do was to
plan a little bit more thoroughly figure
out what places I can still eat in but
just make sure that my food was still
whole thirty approved for example on a
work day all right my usual midday work
field is Chipotle and I initially
thought I couldn't have Chipotle on
whole xxx but boy was I wrong
all I had to do was take out the rice
and beans and I'm good to go and the
cheese obviously so what do I have in my
bowl salad bowl double the meat chicken
mild salsa guacamole and the fajita
vegetables sounds
[Music]
boy did I make a mistake giving up
sweets during the Swedish time of the
year bro I'm trying to stop my first day
at holds already and then what is this
what is this and then what is this it's
ridiculous in here holidays birthdays
retirements there were cakes and
chocolate bars everywhere part of trying
to give something up your success
depends on getting away from those
things I made sure that I didn't have
any sweets in my house I couldn't cheat
but constantly being met with sweets
galore in the hospital that was a
serious challenge for me and I was like
am I gonna give it but for some reason
having those rules made it a little bit
easier because I just deferred to the
rules as opposed to like no I really
shouldn't
[Music]
boy I miss something big what holiday
falls from the middle of November to the
middle of December Thanksgiving how do I
not think this through and on top of it
I was invited to an amazing Thanksgiving
Greek dinner and if you've never had a
Greek dinner the whole thirty struggle
is real on a Greek it's not like my
sous-vide cooking day you saw not too
long ago it's much much better than that
basically all I could put on my plate
was the turkey and some peas because
everything else had cheese on it or some
kind of grain and I was just sitting
there unhappily everyone looked at me
like I was crazy you know that scene for
My Big Fat Greek Wedding what do you
mean you don't eat no meat what do you
mean you don't eat no rice oh it's okay
we have cake oh my go do you know how
bad I want to eat this right now
[Music]
one of the rules of hole 30 is that you
can drink alcohol to me not a big deal
not a big drinker anyway I'll have a
glass of wine or drink here and there
for celebratory purposes but now I went
to Miami for Art Basel if you don't know
what our basil is it's like a
fancy-schmancy art event where the ton
of exhibits in Miami great weather great
people everyone's happy people are
having drinks you never been to Miami a
big part of the celebration during our
faizal's to go out at night I've never
really gone out to nightclubs without
having at least one drink it's not about
getting drunk for me just about you know
like having a drink I'm loosening up but
being out with like 2 Chainz on top of
you singing and I'm there just drinking
water everyone felt like I was a
buzzkill at this thing like have a drink
with us you know cheers Cheers shoes
that I would be cheers in water and
people would get offended I was able to
withstand that but I can easily see how
if you're trying to follow hole 30 the
peer pressure can really motivate
someone to cheat
[Music]
I was moving I was grooving I was
starting to feel good on hole 30 I was
even getting proud telling people like
oh no no rice for me just sushi me or
whatever it is I was eating but then
disaster struck again probably due to
poor planning but it was a true disaster
went to the gym a few times and my bench
started going down which makes no sense
normally like when I'm working out I'm
benching like 225 255 225 was becoming a
huge challenge for me when I stepped
onto the basketball court after one game
I felt like I was exhausted it made no
sense to me it's not because I turned 30
it's probably because I was under eating
my calories when you do an elimination
diet like whole 30 it's very easy to
under each calories this is probably why
a lot of people lose weight but now
myself being an athlete I needed to plan
for that I should have thought more
ahead to make sure that I can still
perform on the court and in the gym
[Music]
once I threw in some extra calories
things improved a lot I was having less
cravings performing better in the gym
actually my body probably looked the
best that it's looked in sometime
following this because I did a lot of
caloric restriction unintentionally and
then kept working out and then off my
protein you just got back from the gym
so I need my little post-workout meal
whole thirty approved we got wild
plaited a little grilled chicken oops I
spilled some I was even already so used
to the eating habits like of things I
couldn't couldn't eat that when I would
go out to eat with somebody and they
would get like an awesome little bun
cake or like some rice something looks
delicious
I wasn't even stressing it anymore like
once you get out of old habits and you
develop new ones it's not that big of a
deal I was actually feeling really good
and proud of myself that I was getting
to the end
[Music]
now when you hit your 30-day mark it's
not over you then enter the phase of
reintroduction of the foods one by one
to see how they would affect your body
because the whole premise of this is not
only to develop a better relationship
with foods but it's also to see if those
foods negatively affect your body this
is like the claim of whole xxx I'm not a
huge fan of it's not really scientific
like if you put in legumes on the first
day then two days later added sugars and
two days after that grains like it's not
scientific if we're doing a proper
elimination challenge in the medical
setting we do a 90-day elimination we
keep a strict log of symptoms we then do
a reintroduction one at a time to see if
and when symptoms return I can put in
legumes on day one day two I can put in
grains and then I have symptoms on day
six and it could be true to any one of
those it's not very scientific because
you don't know what's happening there
[Music]
if you followed my previous 30-day
challenges you know that my digestive
system becomes an absolute mess I mean
bloating diarrhea whenever I make any
kind of drastic changes and believe me
this was a drastic change when I began
that reintroduction phase everything
went back to normal I mean yes I
included more vegetables in my diet but
by doing so everything returned back to
normal I started feeling good again I
just think like these major drastic
changes when you're already eating
healthy probably are great for your
microbiome and your overall gut health
so I find out what I eat my normal diet
that's right for my body and my athletic
needs it works best for me but with more
vegetables something I noticed was that
I was struggling to get my fiber for my
meals because normally I would eat
things like black beans at least three
four times a week brown rice and when I
had to eliminate all those I had to find
replacement sources and yeah vegetables
fruits there's stuff in there I think if
I was to do it again I would probably
supplement with something just to make
sure I get enough fiber
[Music]
one of the main questions people asked
me when I was almost at the end of hole
30 was how did my body change well I
definitely saw some weight loss but
remember part of the rules are no
measurements
I didn't weigh myself when I did notice
was now my clothes were fitting a lot
more loose my pants were a little bag
year even my watch started sort of
hanging on my hand maybe I was losing
muscle because I was under eating
calories but there's definitely ways you
can mitigate all of that depending on
what your goals are that's why my
recommendation is to never just do these
on a whim talk to a nutritionist a
registered dietician a physician
somebody that can give you some guidance
on what you should be doing in fact my
whole gripe with whole 30 is that it
really encourages people to do this on a
whim they're like oh if you're fatigued
try this it may help it's true it may
help especially if you're eating a ton
of junk food but what if you have a
vitamin D deficiency that you're not
aware of and then you do whole 30 you
don't eat dairy and that worsens your
vitamin D deficiency or you're anemic or
something I mean there's so many reasons
why people can have symptoms that's
exactly the reason why you should be
evaluated before you start a drastic
elimination diet like this that's not
knocking whole xxx
that's just spitting facts at the end of
the day nutritional advice should be
individualized but it's a very
restrictive diet I can cause some
serious problems there's definitely some
research showing that there's some
crossover with eating disorders and most
the time it's unnecessary I just feel
that there's other ways of getting
someone to eat healthy than to give them
a strict list of eight things to do and
eliminating some foods that I think are
otherwise healthy why would you
eliminate certain foods like black beans
that can be so healthy to the majority
of people a lot of it doesn't make sense
but look if you want a challenge for
yourself like I did and you want to do
it the safe way make sure you talk to a
nutritionist or a doctor and you do it
the smart way huge thank you to thrive
market for sponsoring this video and
making healthy eating affordable links
in my bio click it sign up get the
12-month package it's only 5 bucks a
month if you want to see my other 30-day
challenges and a green tea video click
on this playlist right here
[Music]